so this would be a little bit of a
different different talk for you guys
instead of talking about pipelines and
deep analysis and algorithms this is
really just a presentation hey this is a
presentation of hey we have a new type
of data we have a new data set that no
one's ever had access to before and I
wanted to let you guys know about it and
give you a preview into it and also give
you guys some examples that you could
not better that better all right can you
guys that's better okay all right that's
kind of weird so all right let me start
over then so I'm here at this talk will
be a little different it's not about
pipelines it's not about deepen at
analytics it's not about it's not about
you know machine learning and modeling
it's the data part and it's introducing
you guys to a new data set it's this
debt has never been available before so
I i did my postdoc in machine learning
and whatever that new dataset hit from
your experiment like you got all excited
right and so hopefully I can impart some
of that on you so let me begin if you're
interested if you're interested there's
the QR code you can hit the download
this presentation live or there's the
short link if you want it let me while
you do that let me tell you a little bit
about myself so I got my PhD in
computational biology then I switched
tracks and I did my machine learning
postdoc in protein functional annotation
then I switched off and I went into
product management and and did some
other really cool things so now I
completely switched gears out of the
biological field into commercial real
estate which is it just a totally crazy
change but it's been a lot of fun so I
work your real massive I'm the CTO there
and so I head up technology and real
massive is a start-up out of Austin
doing commercial real estate we are the
first open first fully opened commercial
real estate data and marketing platform
and we're here to solve what we call the
commercial real estate data problem this
is really just taking the commercial
real estate industry from last
generation to this generation or
actually from maybe two generations ago
and try
to get it technologically up to date and
it's been an interesting challenge so
let me give you a very quick live demo
as to how this looks so yep so what you
can do is you can search for office
space and different types of office
space you can look in Dallas and any of
the other markets that we've launched
rope we're covering over 4 billion
square feet of space and where our
attempt at solving this data problem and
let me actually clarify what the data
problem is the data problem is the fact
that those who own and control all the
commercial real estate data it's very
closed and they charge you for the
simplest access to it and because of
this very non open nature it creates
inefficiencies in the marketplace
everywhere from beginning your lease
negotiation to like finding space to
doing the negotiations to sealing the
deal and to building out at the end on
top of that because since no one has
this information counties and realist
and in states and the government have a
very difficult time creating the
knowledge that they need to know about
the commercial real estate industry and
also creating analytics and other bi on
top of that so I mean let me quickly
search for some space here just do a
Dallas okay so that the resolution is
obviously tiny so it's rolling up into
its rolling up into like mobile view now
because the resolutions Willie it's so
so Simone so let's get this i'll go back
to the slides i presented before so my
worst case scenario is to make sure you
have a backup plan and here we go so the
main page you can search on the left you
have the real-time view for the map and
on the right you have list results and
you can if you're searching for space
this is all free so just go to Rome a
SOCOM and start your search you can save
your list of favorites which you can
have on the right there and you have
your profile you can collaborate with
other people everything else so what
does this have to do with data right and
we also have a mobile app coming out so
before I talk about data I want to talk
about the value of commercial real
estate this this is a real motivating
factor here
I really love this example I did it made
this for a presentation a while back and
it's really it's a great example so
what's the value in commercial real
estate again because no one had access
to this information before very few
people knew this so let's do a quick
calculation what's the yearly economic
impact of one class a building and often
so this is the frost bank tower and it's
a half a million square feet and the
average running rate for it right now is
about $51 a square foot so about thirty
dollars a square foot to rent plus
twenty dollars a square foot for
operation expenses which is like
insurance and taxes and things like that
so this building has a yearly economic
yearly economic impact of about twenty
six million dollars in Austin just if it
was fully rented out and that's not the
business that's going on there that's
simply just leasing out this space 26
million dollars for one building for one
year i think that's that's pretty
incredible and if you take that and you
expand it across the u.s. just the u.s.
2014 the federal reserve is has
calculated that it's worth fifteen point
two trillion dollars to the t the asset
base is huge and this is an industry
with outdated data management and search
practices and so we're here to like i
said bring it into the next generation
so next time you see the skyline i hope
you can have a different appreciation to
the value that's floating above the
horizon and look at all those buildings
i was just one building in austin wasn't
the biggest wasn't the nicest but it's
just an amazing how much value there's
okay so that's the pitch for commercial
real estate is valuable let's talk about
the data portion and how you guys can
get access to it so this is our stack
this is a very simple simple
architecture diagram the bottom you know
we're on the Google cloud platform we
have chosen Python you can choose Java
or Python all of our back-end workers in
Python and we love it we built a REST
API on top of that which is how you guys
will get access to the information and
we also have a mobile app and a web app
built on there as well okay very simple
our data so currently this is as of a
couple days ago or as of yesterday we
are currently live in 33 markets we plan
to
and out in a 99 we have over 33,000
buildings covering over 78,000 spaces
and historically caught for the past
year or so that's a 400,000 edits to
those spaces so we can start to track
some historical information as well and
on top of that because it is a marketing
and data platform we have over 84,000
pieces of media movies etc that you guys
can get access to for these buildings on
the right oh this is gonna be painful
okay on the right is a JSON payload that
no one can read we'll see how this goes
so how do you get access to our data
it's really simple just use our API
right has anybody used apiary if you
guys ever heard of a peer it's it's
awesome so apiary is an API documenting
and framework sort of a testing tool so
how API is how we used to develop api's
as we'd sit down to the editor we'd set
up some routes and we'd lead you know
and code them up and then someone would
come along and say oh I'd like to use
that we'd go document and we'd add some
tests or whatever right this is this
takes a different approach which is you
go in there and you document this in a
strict format and in a templated format
and then what happens is that
documentation turns into mock code that
you can write your application against
and then so you just fill out the
template for your routes and set up your
mock payloads and then you can import
requests and you can make you know
python calls against their mock server
so really it's a beautiful tool on top
of that it's live it's it is
documentation so check out apiary if
you're writing any API is really really
good tool so our API is restful
everybody's got a restful api right we
support the basic crud ops crud
operations create reading and updating
of records you can search you know you
text search you can do geo search you
can filter sort we support projection
queries and it's also in we believe
pretty intuitive layout for the API so
you know restful api is have nothing
really to say about how you let your
routes it's really just a set of
constraints on an architecture but we've
done is we because we want people to use
the api we obviously spent a lot of time
trying to make it intuitive so let's
talk about the api
so the first thing that we have is
markets and so think commercial real
estate there's residential real estate
and in this commercial right so you live
in you live in your house that's
residential you work in an office
building this commercial so we have
markets in a market is a geographic
region that we serve and the end point
for that is a PIV one markets and if you
want to grab an individual market it's a
PIV one markets and then you just give
it the unique key string now the trick
about markets is a market as commercial
real estate or CRE professionals define
it is it's one or more cities and so
it's not just like Austin is a market
Boston is a market dallas-fort Worth
combined is a market so it's multiple
cities okay and you can also search for
markets as well a PIV when markets geo
and you can do a geo search you just
give us a lot long will give you the
closest market to that search up to that
point so okay good so that that payload
we can read so the result from the
example results from the market search
gives you the last time it was edited at
gives you the list of cvd centers and
submarkets unique keys the submarkets
within it and the market name so if you
pull it down you can store this
information and if you want to get a
unique market lighter just you can just
get it with a key very simple I think
the key here is that so within a market
we have a list of cities so you have
Dallas Fort Worth is the market that
professionals identify and in there is
what we call the CBD centers and the CBD
centers are a list of cities that
comprise that market and then within the
CBD centers you have the submarket okay
so within markets you have buildings all
right so buildings go inside markets
these represent the physical the
physical buildings that people work in
and the end point for that is hiv-1
buildings and you know we try to be
consistent so a PIV when buildings key
string dude get on that route and you're
going to get the information back for a
building and then to do a search it's a
PIV when buildings search and then you
provide the list of parameters okay
again following a pretty pretty specific
pattern I'll talk about search in a
second because our search is quite
quick and very very flexible I think
this is for application developers this
is going to be I think nice okay so
that's kind of hard to read so but let
me roll through it because there are
some stuff that's kind of interesting
this again is a representation of a
building a physical structure so you
have you know bullied does it have air
conditioning how big is it what are the
units that were measuring its size in
what's the submarket that it's in who do
we notify whenever we need to
communicate things about this building
what's the parking look like what market
is it in does have sprinklers what's the
building called and then there's another
one called space key space keys towards
the bottom and this is a list of spaces
in the building so you have a building
and then within the building you have a
bunch of these civil units called spaces
right and if you want to get access to
those you just grab a space key from
that space keys list and then you do a
get on that space key and I'll show you
in a second buildings also have type are
their office retail industrial flex
there's operating expenses we have a
very thorough financial record for each
building that's going to be it's not out
yet we have a minimal financial record
nah but we have a very flushed out one
coming very soon and zoning tendency
just a lot of other things and then
because it has a point on land we also
have the address the city the zip the
county of the state the street and so if
you start thinking about what the
information you can get back from this
don't think about serving the the
commercial real estate community
necessarily but start thinking about you
know financial markets I can now start
pulling down information about you know
these very valuable entities in my my
city question not yet so we have we have
so the question was do we have the
census block in for for these locations
not yet we're working with at least a
dozen different data providers to pull
in other information and there's I have
yet I just started actually looking into
using the free and information like
census information from the government
okay so we had markets we had buildings
and I mean now we have spaces right this
is that these are the typical units of
measure which someone is going to
promote
and so the end point here is a PIV one
spaces if you're going to pull down I
sound like a broken record but if you're
going to pull down an individual one
it's a PIV one spaces and the key string
and then to search for them it's a PIV
one space is searched and then you
probably provide your list of parameters
I mean it's like I said very
straightforward let me just talk about
the payload four spaces so we have
there's a title we have is it featured
or promoted which is um so obviously if
it's a marketing platform people want
this in front of as many people as
possible so they will promote spaces to
pay for that we have a short URL so you
can get access to this in the future is
it contiguous or divisible how much is
the is the marketing manager trying to
charge for this what's the rate per
square foot for example we have an
optimized URL so it doesn't it's it's a
pretty URL essentially the type of rate
and interest of just a bunch of other
information that you would need to make
it an informed decision about the
quality of the space for your needs okay
I'm not going to roll through the entire
API because I'm you know I put everybody
to sleep I'm sure but I would like to
let you know that there are a few other
models we have the user model so after
you login a PIV one user will bring back
your user information so if you off your
if you're making an application that
supports multiple users you can offer
them into our system and pull back their
information api v1's surveys so a survey
a market survey is a tool that
professionals use to it's essentially
just a list of their favorite spaces
based on certain criteria so let's say
the vp of google flies in and says
listen I need 200,000 square feet in
downtown Dallas it's got to be above the
16th floor because all my people have a
great view and it has all these
properties or attributes you can do a
search on our system and then add them
to your survey for your customer and
then one of the nice features we have on
surveys is the ability to do you find
similar spaces to what you have in your
survey so you know we have thousands and
thousands of spaces and so you may not
know and we don't even expect you to
know what's in the database so you can
hit a PIV one surveys and then
recommendations and we'll give you a
list of recommendations that look
exactly like what you already have in
there there's also the attachments
that's for media and uploads we also
have the version what current version
are we serving which is API version and
then buildings and spaces now have
amenities to amenities would be like you
know this as a gym or this out of the
coffee shop or there's a swimming pool
or something like that it's just a free
form tag and you can pull those down as
well so now this this is to me this is
where we get kind of interesting so I
now have the supply information we are
recording the demand which is what
people are you know when people come to
our site what are they doing so now we
have a marketplace we have supply and
demand and now because of the
information that we're providing you I
can start to ask some really interesting
questions like well if I go east of 35
what happens to the the average rate per
square foot for a class a building or
what happens if I go west of 35 but
what's the occupancy rated this building
and that the last one is a really good
example because if I'm a banker and I'm
someone comes to me and says I'd like to
build this hundred million dollar
building as a banker if everything goes
well i'm gonna make six percent on 100
million so i'm going to make six million
off they're off that loan right if
everything goes south let's say that the
building like they can't lease the
building and everything fails I'm out a
hundred million dollars so there's a
huge amount of risk so now given this I
can do I can report back on the status
of the buildings and the spaces and say
hey your buildings at twenty-two percent
occupancy that that's the banker he's
going to say oh that's that's terrible
I'm gonna flip them and get rid of this
building i'm gonna sell it to someone
and on the other side there's someone
who is who wants to take that risk
there's a product where people say okay
well its twenty two percent occupancy
but it's in an area that's being brought
up you know the crime rates going down
and I'm gonna take that risk so there's
an equal equal sides in this marketplace
but just really interesting potential
here and that no one ever had before so
let me give you a very simple search
example how do you find if you're going
to write code on this after you do
import request and Python how are you
gonna get your spaces well let's say you
want to search Dallas it's just a PIV
one space to search and then you pass in
building address that city is dallas
right and then this would return to you
the JSON payload
the first page of the entire payload so
there's in our database as of yesterday
there were two thousand four hundred and
eighty seven spaces that match that
query and we would return the first 80
to you with a cursor and the search
results what you do then is you take the
cursor you store your 80 results you
take the cursor and pass that back into
the same search and we recognize hey
that's the cursor and then we give you
page two and then we'll give you a new
curse or new results you pass the cursor
back you get page three and so on until
the cursors know okay we also have
throttling so we don't want you two to
shut down the entire database from us
and ruin the customer experience for the
professionals using the site so we will
throttle you what you do is just provide
exponential back-off yeah that's right
we'll provide so provide exponential
back-off in your queries if you're going
to do large queries and multiple pages
so what you do is you wait two seconds
you query again if you get a 429 you
wait four seconds again 429 you wait
until you get the result and then you
can continue query but look how flexible
this can really be now so I hate dense
slides but this I just had to type all
the text up there so in order to search
okay let the example is I want to find
all the spaces in Dallas proper better
between twenty dollars a square foot and
thirty to fifty a square foot exclusive
so strictly greater than 20 and strictly
less than 30 to 50 in the central
expressway submarket better between
fifty five hundred and twelve thousand
two hundred square feet inclusive
managed by the management company called
peloton sorted by increasing rate and
decreasing size so then take those
results and then filter out everything
but the size the title and the
geolocation okay and so here's the query
would look like a PIV when spaces search
and the parameter lists of building
address city is dallas this wouldn't
give you the market of dallas but again
just the dallas city proper and then
building that submarket equals central
expressway and the right equals and then
you'll see the minimum colon max so 20
from 20 to 30 to 50 a square foot and if
you have parenthesis this is how that's
how we do ranges we just do we do
minimum colon max that's how you specify
a range for our API and then the
parentheses are exclusive and the
brackets are inclusive so this says find
me an exclusive range of twenty twenty
to thirty to fifty a square foot and
this says find me the inclusive range
from fifty five hundred twelve thousand
two hundred square feet okay and the
building managers name is peloton and
okay now this is the projection this is
the choir the filter where I say only
return to me the space available the
rate and then the Latin long and then
after you've done that then I need it
sorted by rate and then you'll see the
model you see the minus sign right here
that's how you specify decreasing sort
on space below so rates should be going
up and then space should be going down
here are the results you'll see that the
very first line is cursor is no and the
very last line number found is five so
there's no more pages I got five results
IV a lighted the list but you'll see
that the first two entries are the space
available is 9930 one square feet the
second one is eight thousand two hundred
and sixty-three so you see the space
available is decreasing as I asked for
and then the rate is increasing okay so
a quick trick for our API all of our
models the market spaces building
surveys you whatever that are searchable
have this extra half year called fields
and that it's a self documenting API
it'll tell you how you can search so you
hit a PIV when spaces search fields and
it will return you at JSON payload
saying hey you can search by space in
size and rate and so on and so forth
okay so now that you know that you have
access to the data and where to find it
let me give you just a few examples I'm
almost done here and taking too much
time at all of just some motivating
examples of how you could use this
information in your applications okay so
i have i have the demand side of the
market which is people coming to our
website so what I've done what I did is
I queried restore results in keene I
query keen and that downloaded the
doesn't
200 and like 50,000 interactions from
keene I joined them into our into our
big table database which I then imported
the [ __ ] then I used DC d3 to create
this plot and this is actually an
interactive plot if it's not in the
presentation to show the demand by state
so we're a start-up we believe it around
for 16 months and so this is essentially
about 10 to 12 months of data you'll see
that Texas's has the highest demand that
we started in Texas we've been there the
longest we have Austin Dallas Fort Worth
San Antonio Houston and then we rolled
out to the other states that are not
obviously zero so okay so we can measure
demand but I can break this down by
county so now think about going to you
know the local business development
organizations in your city and having
this level of information for them I
think they'd find it quite useful so now
we have county-based information and
this I like this plot is actually pretty
cool the supply in Austin so what I did
here is I went to our database and I
said okay I did the API v when space is
search and then I said give me
everything in the Austin market and then
I said I used to projection query and I
said give me the lat/long of all those
spaces okay then I just pulled that down
and created the heat map I'm using pi
[ __ ] and [ __ ] [ __ ] DC and d3 and I'm
sorry run fine this is just google maps
this is a google maps email sorry but
what you'll notice is that downtown
Austin there's a big red glob of spaces
and then you'll notice that there's a
pretty good distribution throughout the
rest of Austin so that's the current
supply those are where people are trying
to lease spaces right and downtown is
obviously the hot spot I don't see
anything there that seems kind of crazy
well let's look at the demand the demand
i thought was really interesting you'll
notice that there's hot spots all around
Austin Austin is you know is kind of on
fire right now downtown's really popular
but what you'll also notice is that
there's some really high intensity
places that are not in downtown and this
is all qualitative because I this is
just plots like 36 hours old
and I did I hadn't actually run the math
yet but what I think we're seeing here
is that traffic in Austin is getting so
bad now that people say downtown is
great but I need to be closer to
somewhere that's not downtown somewhere
close to where I live and then you'll
also notice that if you look at downtown
Austin you see the bright red spot so
downtown people don't seem to care where
you are downtown just as long as you're
downtown downtown that's not the big red
glob says but if you look at outside of
downtown you notice that where the high
intensity plots are there are pretty
much all near highways it's kind of cool
the stuff that I don't think I mean it's
obvious but you know I don't think
people have ever had this information
before and couldn't ask and answer these
questions and then let's get look at the
rates it's the same idea give me all the
spaces let's look at the rates downtown
obviously has it has a benefit of higher
rates but if you look on the west side
just west of west lake hills there and
also south of Boston you'll see that
there are some some high intensity spots
so people think they can get higher
rates for those areas kind of
interesting I can also do frequency of
updates because we have the historical
data I can look at I can look at how
well people are updating their data and
try to figure out what's going on maybe
there's a market where there's much
higher churn than another market maybe
there's a manager who just is fantastic
at keeping our data up-to-date we could
look at that and see that right away so
this is that's dfw here's Austin so as
you see again downtown has a higher turn
so downtown really is the hot spot but
there's that one place just south of the
river that has a real high turnover kind
of interesting so this is just a list of
examples and I really thank you for your
attention I know this is a complete
aside from what you normally would have
expected to see her but I wanted to just
let you know that the data that there is
a new data source that is never existed
we're growing it across the nation
there's extreme amount of value here and
I just wanted to present that to you
guys today I'd like to acknowledge my
dev team and launch team at real massive
they've done a fantastic
job we have a small team and a start-up
and we were just there there there
killing it and then also Mike Bostock I
just found some of he had some he has
years of beautifully organized work on
geo were geo geo everything and so I
pulled down some of them for his
information converted it from geo Jason
and topo Jason made the maps so that you
guys could see the information so and
last and this is really exciting for me
so we're hiring and so again I guy I did
my machine did my postdoc in machine
learning and I'm just real i love data
and i love getting my hands on data and
especially being the first person to see
a new data set like you and knowing
within getting a chance to you know
explore it and see what's in there so
we're looking for chief data scientist
and senior senior engineer for data
science and as well as other positions
so if you're interested or just want to
see what we have or just want to chat
i'm happy just to chat to please let me
know please come find me afterwards we
are hiring and we have a live a great
culture people have a lot of fun so with
that I thank you for your attention and
they'll take any questions you guys have
yeah the question was do we track
special types of information regarding
spaces or building so each building has
a type and it can be office retail
medical industrial or flex space and
we're building that list out they've is
I think a list of like 60 or 70 fields
and it doesn't actually belong in the
building that belongs on the space so
removing that actually to the space
level because if you go to New York
you'll have mixed and the real of retail
on the first floor and then you'll have
office throughout the rest so there's
mixed buildings but yeah we do track
that yeah
yeah that's a great question so what
about sort of more flexible uses to
toward space i think is the question
right do we have stuff of that nature
right so we are yes we have co-working
coming I've already been in contact with
many of the co-working organizations in
the US some of them are pretty excited
to get on we we don't have what you're
asking for yet but this platform is
fully capable of handling that so the
co-working will be coming soon we have
to do for sale first so we're doing
lease number doing for sale and then
we'll do land but it we're co-working
and there's also another type called
Lisa the leased space which is our
license space which is essentially
renting a desk so you read them there's
this thing they call shadow space which
is if okay you rent 8,000 square feet
for your your new business value but you
only need six thousand all right so
you've got a couple thousand left over
what do you do with it right so you put
a desk there you put a few chairs you
got Wi-Fi got some sodas and then you go
up and you list that chair to someone
who can use your Wi-Fi and your
facilities and you rent those those out
that's becoming more and more popular
it's similar to co-working there's a
company that does that as well and we're
gonna be using their information as well
yeah go ahead it's just
yeah so well we we have a very so our
main competitors make the the biggest
competitor is a multi-billion dollar
industry and they make six hundred
million dollars a year off of selling
the data we intend to disrupt that we
have but because they do such a speak to
pulley of them but they don't do a very
good job serving their customers and so
the customers are very happy to give us
their information and so it hasn't been
a challenge it's been hey look what
we're doing and would you like to be on
the platform yes here's our information
okay so you just go to that we go
straight down the list top 25 in each
market based on land holding and say or
values and say would you like to be on
the platform once number one comes on we
say hey number one came on doing and go
to number two and say look what they're
doing and then it's a competitive
advantage they're very much into it and
the market pretty much falls / you from
the that's right and that also that also
helps us get higher quality data as well
so what we do so I presented you the API
side and there's an entire other side to
what we do and this is creating a suite
of tools to help those who manage the
data keep their data up-to-date keep it
fresh so that people the application
developers can have real data to use and
the people looking for space have have
relevant and up-to-date information to
use and so we make these tools to make
those people's lives easier so they keep
the data today that's right I can
quantify how many hours a week or month
i can save I can take the ever Justin I
can guesstimate the salary and as long
as I'm capturing a fraction of that
value yeah
yep so that was the demand slide we're
tracking so we do track what people do
track demand we haven't yet open that up
for API developers to pull down yet we
just haven't gotten there where we're
trying to make sure that the main thing
is let's get the data into our system
let's keep it fresh and then we can
build out from there so but yeah that's
what that slide is and where I'm I can't
wait to see that to even more and more
of it yeah yeah and yeah and on top of
that once we have the market you know
supply and demand then you know business
intelligence comes down there analytics
tools that you guys can hit from api
from api routes not just pulling down
space and building information doing the
work yourself so right now the industry
uses quarterly reports what'll happen is
okay so someone will go do research for
four to six weeks on the past 90 days
and then they they do this work and then
they distribute the information that's
now 120 150 days old and it's so far to
date but that's the best they have and
they're making informed decisions on
that I intend to create an endpoint that
collects information directly from the
system now and downloads your PDF and
here you go there's a no longer is it is
it a quarterly report it's a trailing
quarterly report from now and so you get
up-to-date risk information and all
sorts of you know uptime the information
yeah
yeah so good question so the first one
was we're awesome thank you it's a lot
of hard work and the teams are they're
very diligent very sedulous at what they
do but again because of because our
customers are underserved and and our
they want to get off the other platform
that conversation has really been a lot
easier than we expected and why App
Engine we have a good time with App
Engine I see it as a as a time to market
thing for me so we could go cured I
could I could go pure DevOps where I
built up everything I could go pure App
Engine which is essentially a hundred
percent managed or I could do ECT to the
amazon web services which are I think
somewhere in the middle our team still
small right now that I'm gonna I'm gonna
offload whatever I can and make sure my
guys are developing instead of trying to
set up even even if they try to pull up
a you know I'm you know imagine machine
in the cloud they're not coding they're
not creating you know so that's why it's
it just works for us and in the back
and so the question is do we overlay
other information on top of our
information the answer is we don't yet
but we definitely have plans to crime
rates traffic rates you know one of the
one of the features I want to build in
is you provide the addresses of you know
let's say the your your team and then
you take that survey tool i showed you
which is your sort of your favorites
list and then you can calculate best
traffic times to and from and take that
in as a dimension that you know you have
more than just rate and size and floor
number now you know it takes you 22
minutes to get there in traffic and then
40 to go home or something like that
that's going to really inform you we
don't have that yet but we're starting
where we're just now to the point where
i got a higher my data to my chief data
science officer and we're gonna roll all
that in yep any others you guys I mean
yeah
hmm
and they've been so many none stand out
as well it wasn't the data collection I
I think one of the reasons why all right
so I'm I don't know how to answer your
question because there's so many there's
so many pitfalls but I do want to say
sort of addressing one of your comments
was other companies have failed at doing
this because they have not taken the
time to properly listen to the customers
what they've done is like a Russian say
hey I'm a technologist I can solve your
problems you're using last generation
technology this is easy and they come in
and they compete with well-established
personas in the marketplace in in the
business model that they shouldn't be
competing with or they they focus on the
wrong people at the wrong time and then
it kills their data so luckily we we
have a very sort of servant leader
leadership approach to how we run the
company we listen to customers very very
closely to figure out what they need and
what they're not going to do and then
there's just a lot of really small like
seemingly small decisions that you can
make that if you're not paying attention
to your customers will will sink the
effort there's an it's awesome I really
appreciate your attention and great
questions feel free to talk to me
afterwards if you have any more and you
want API tokens to get access to the API
let me know it like like I said it is
free of charge so you guys can get at it
awesome thanks for your tension